foreign
are the major currencies of our lives
today
over the last couple of decades we've
seen data going from being wired to
becoming Wireless
and this has helped democratize access
to information
can we do the same thing with energy
can we send energy when we want where we
want and as much as we want and in the
process eliminate the last wire
if you could do this the possibilities
would be endless
from Earth to space
I'd like to tell you about our dream of
wireless energy transfer today
it starts with something we are all
familiar with waves
so waves are very essential to our lives
you can hear this talk because of
acoustic waves
you can see this talk because of a
certain kind of electromagnetic waves
called light
and the odds are if you're watching it
on the internet you're using some sort
of Wireless connectivity that relies on
wireless and RF waves
if you have two ways that have the same
frequency and going are going up and
down and they come together in some
point in space
they will add and make a wave that's
twice the height
but care is four times the energy
now if the same two waves come together
at some other place in space but one is
running half a period late
they cancel
and you get very little energy
practically no energy
this is the basis for a process that has
been known for for a long time
it's called interference the idea here
is that if you go and sit at the edge of
a pond and take both hands and put them
in the water and move them up and down
each hand makes a wave
but because of the interaction of these
waves there will be some directions
where you get more energy and there's
some directions that you will get less
can we make it go only in One Direction
well you need more hands
and they have to go perfectly
synchronized
but if you do that what happens is that
most of your energy starts traveling
straight down
now this is a remarkable thing because
if you think about each one of those
little hands each one of those little
sources they would send energy all over
the place but they when they work
together
the result is that the energy is going
mostly in One Direction
now if the timing was the reason for
this happening maybe we can play with it
maybe we can mess with it
and see what happens so what if each one
of these sources goes a little bit after
the one next to it
so in that case what happens is that
these waves start going in different
directions and you can change that
direction
purely by controlling timing
and nothing else
now this makes it possible to change
this direction without any mechanical
movement so it can be almost
instantaneous
you can go even farther you can think
about creating a magnifying glass
a focusing system but you can actually
send the energy most of it close to 90
percent of it in one focal point
but again since you are controlling the
timing
you can create different focal points
and you can send it to them
and this is the basis for wireless
energy transfer
it's as if you have an army of ants
that are working in perfect
synchronization
and each one of them contributes a
little bit of energy
but as a whole they send it to the right
place
now
obviously here timing is everything like
life and comedy
okay
so we've taken this concept and we've
built this
electronic chips integrated circuits
that each one of them generates a little
bit of power but again as a group they
are designed to work in perfect
synchronization and drive these little
antennas that transmit the energy
now this army of ants or Army of
antennas is working together to create
those focal points of energy
and what I will show you next is some
examples of how that actually operates
so what you have here for example is a
generator unit that's sending power
wirelessly to the two receivers and here
the point is to see how well defined
these focal points are
that led panels basically is receiving
that power and showing it so you can see
energy is going only where it needs to
go and nowhere else
you can take this and put one of these
generators on the ceiling of your
conference room or your living room and
transmit energy to various devices that
you need energy
now this generator on the ceiling is
going to power a light bulb
now as we move the light bulb what
happens is that you see that there's no
energy in the new location but the
system finds it tracks it and send it
sends it to the new location
and you can see that it dynamically
tracks it back and forth
you can use this to send energy to one
light bulb
go to the next one or to both of them at
the same time
now you can use something like this for
example to power a drone this is a
battery less drone
that's being purely powered by the
generator facing up from the bottom and
it can also use the same tracking
approach to track the Drone
so now that we know that we can send NG
wirelessly
the question is how far can we go
really how far can we go
could we put photovoltase in space
solar panels in space
and Collective energy and send that
wirelessly to Earth
this is not a new idea
the first time it was mentioned it was
was in a short story science fiction
story by Isaac Asimov from 1941.
and what I love about this story is that
it's about a self-conscious
robot
and the humans describing this idea to
the self-conscious robot
after which the robot says
do you expect me to believe such a
far-fetched crazy notion what do you
take me for
the first question almost always is us
is that why do you want to put your
solar panels in space
why didn't you put them up at the dead
in the desert and be done with it right
few reasons
first is that in space you get about
eight times more energy
because you don't have day and night
you don't have clouds you don't have
seasons and you don't have the
atmosphere atmospheric absorption
also now that you have this availability
to send that energy where you want and
when you want dynamically
you can imagine that you have
dispatchable power
on top of that it's an always available
power
this can be used for a place for example
let's say a an island hit by a hurricane
or there's no power
or a city in war zone where the power
infrastructure is being constantly
attacked
you can think about using this to send
power to a remote Village in sub-Saharan
Africa where there is no infrastructure
for power transmission
and that way democratize the access to
energy
or send it somewhere above the Arctic
Circle
so all of these things are great
but the question is if it has been known
for such a long time and it's such a
great thing why hasn't it been done so
far
the main reason is that the way it has
been envisioned before they've been
thinking about it as a big elephant
if you're thinking about putting big
solar panels in space collecting the
power generating a lot of energy and
then putting into a massive
a parabolic dish antenna and sending it
to a fixed location on Earth
sending things to space is expensive you
pay dollars and that's plural per gram
the other problem is that even if you
could afford it
assembly of something like this in space
still beyond the capabilities that we
have today
so we came up with a very different
approach where we took our
generators and turn them into flexible
fabric-like structures
we are utilizing that amazing power of
electronics integrated electronics and
the flexible Electronics to make this
very lightweight flexible fabric like
structures that you can draw and pack
and this allows you to have this
satellite packed
for launch and deployed in space where
each one of these units would be about
several tens of meters on the side and
then you can have a pack of whole bunch
of them and create a constellation of
them that flies in space and forms your
power station to send green energy to
Earth
this will be flying in formation
around the earth obviously this is not
the size of the planet because we're
talking about a kilometer across for the
whole whole constellation and the flat
is a little bit larger than the
kilometer
we've been developing as a proof of
concept technology demonstrator and this
is called Maple which demonstrates the
power of flexible structures and
electronic circuitry to generate and
transmit power in space
we integrated that with two other
technology demonstrators for Deployable
structures and photovoltaics that were
developed by three teams led by myself
and two of my colleagues and we
integrated into a satellite that was
launched
recently
and the purpose of this experiment has
been to demonstrate the power transfer
Wireless power transfer in space
now that brings me
to the back to the promise of wireless
energy transfer and what it could mean
for us
I believe this technology is too
compelling to go away
and I believe it's bound to appear in
our lives in one form or another and
that is something to look forward to
thank you
[Applause]